les mois ça un tour du monde à la voile
en solitaire
je trouve ça pathétique je trouve ça
profond héroïque cette fois c'est sans
escale ça n'a jamais été entreprise
c'est le summum
on ne peut pas faire mieux ceux qui
participent devrait aller se faire
examiner examine moi donc tu veux j'ai
déjà envoyé mon dossier d'inscription
quoi quoi tu parle sérieusement clair tu
étais au courant non gens savaient se
faire examiner nous prendre des claques
mais tonique jeux sans décrocher la
prime pour toi mon amour 5009 moi tout
seul sur un bateau il faut que tu sois
soudainement et bien reprenant tout de
suite un autre verre histoire d'écarter
l'hypothèse de la démence comme l'a dit
chichester n'importe quel idiot peut
faire le tour du monde en étant sobre
seul un excellent marin peut le faire en
étant sous la même chose en fait vous
n'êtes pas vraiment navigateur il me
semble que le simple fait de naviguer
fait de vous un navigateur vous dites
moi monsieur holdsworth comment êtes
vous devenue attachée de presse 1 j'ai
été journaliste pendant un temps à la
rubrique criminel donc votre expérience
d'attaché presse semble comparable à mon
expérience de navigateurs touché
monsieur crohas
seulement voilà la publicité est un
métier qui s'exerce eux tranquillement
du fond de sa chaise barea bateau c'est
un tout autre exercice que vous
adversaire maîtrise parfaite monsieur
lauwers personne n'a l'expérience d'un
tour du monde à la voile en solitaire et
sans escale pour la bonne et simple
raison que ça n'a jamais été fait mais
prenez par exemple le français la moité
siennois tessier il a déjà navigué
depuis tahiti jusqu'au cap horn à
travers l'océan austral
deux autres prix un foutu canot à rames
pour traverser l'atlantique un autre
pendant la guerre commandait un
sous-marin mois tessier knox johnston
tête les autres sont sans doute des
marins chevronnés mais quand je
remporterai le golden age
s'il vous plaît vous ne pouvez pas
croire que vous allez gagner le simple
fait de prendre la mer est déjà un
exploit pour twister avait une moyenne
quotidienne de trente et un mille
nautique sur son ketch estime pouvoir
atteindre les 200 sur un trimaran
je vais vous dire ce que je vois quand
je vous regarde vous même je vois une
part de l'angleterre aujourd'hui disparu
c'est par téméraire que churchill su
réveiller lorsque les bombes pleuvaient
cet emprunteur qui ne baisse jamais les
bras
je vous le dit donald crowhurst il ya en
vous un récit de bravoure qui ne demande
qu'à être racontée nos rêves sont les
racines de nos actes tâchons de ne
jamais l'oublier
une course en solitaire autour du monde
mais j'ai déjà envoyé mon dossier
d'inscription
je veux te faire remarquer que je n'a
pas un bateau conçu pour un pareil
voyage aux jeunes vont construire déjà
fait quoi que ce soit de ce genre
non justement si je peux le faire alors
monsieur tout le monde peut le faire lui
aussi moi jouer l'argent sur la terre
vous vous mettez quoi touristes
je me suis persuadé qu'on faisait que
construire un bateau je ne réalisais pas
qu'un jour je devrais te regarder partir
un homme seul sur un bateau se
retrouvent soumis à une énorme pression
de la mer et sans pitié
on sent les concurrents en tête ils ont
trois mines métal ans si je poursuis mes
chances de survie sont de 50 50 si je
fais demi tour
c'est la ruine assurée
je ne peux ni continuer où il rentrait
je suis ici et si je leur disais que je
suis
là cette semaine est un gros obstacle
icd vitesse exceptionnelle que si je
faire maintenant il n'y a plus que moi
j'ai cru que je serai plus forts à ce
jeu-là
nous sommes tous reliés les uns aux
autres
peu importe la distance qui ne s'est pas
demain et tous les jours qui suivront
les enfants auront toujours besoin de
leur père j'aurai toujours besoin de mon
mari
la vie doit être vécue restait alors à
demander ce qu'on peut faire
pour lui donner un sens
[Musique]